AOC snapping and left-wing activist and
team Vogue who painted her as a
hypocrite the lefties are angry that she
hosted a high school recruitment event
that had representatives from military
service academies AOC has fought to ban
similar armed services recruiting
tactics so now the Socialist is
scrambling to reassure liberals that she
hates Uncle Sam
someone made a made up a rumor that I
me was hosting a military recruitment
Fair
for high schoolers does that sound like
something I would do I was really
subject to
a lot of really
vile
rhetoric and attacks all day to day
um
because of a rumor and I can't stress
how much this is not just a right-wing
thing it's an opportunity for all of us
to pause and take a breath because it's
not all what it looks like sometimes
it's true but that kind of far left
anti-military mentality could be behind
the big drop in recruitment Pentagon
officials say they're facing the
greatest recruiting challenge in almost
half a century so
she was under Fire Dana for uh allegedly
helping like just having the military at
a recruitment event probably an
employment event she claims he didn't
have it but just the idea that that is
offensive
it's vile and I'm pretty sure she
supports what's going on in Ukraine
right so they could have an army Ukraine
can have an army but not the United
States does she understand how Ukraine
is fighting Russia right do you think
they're just Pixies from The Woodlands
coming down from the sky how about when
she said does that sound like me it's
like absolutely not it does not sound
like something you would do because you
are outrageous remember when the left
was mad at the Pentagon for spending
money on recruitment efforts at NASCAR
events yes and they said that that was
so outrageous and a total waste of money
and how crazy that was was like well
where do you think you actually recruit
you try to recruit everywhere one of the
big problems is they have problems with
people that can't pass a fitness test
there's an obesity problem the people
that actually have different options but
right now because job Market's pretty
good you can get out there there but you
know she also says she wants free
college for everyone here's a great way
you could actually pay for college you
can join the military that's a one one
way you could also maybe find a great
career there and the other thing is you
could get into something like exciting
like the space force which is one of the
hottest recruiting things the military
has kill people from space Dana yep oh
that is just terrible yeah let that let
the Chinese do that we're not going to
take part in that get your hands dirty
you know Jessica it's I find it funny
that it was Teen Vogue that was
criticizing aoct phone has done more to
hurt young people that the military ever
could it is why why is this there Emma
what happened to Teen Vogue shouldn't it
be all about fashion and bulimia
the face of publishing has changed and
they became super political after that
gaslighting article remember they came
out like three four years ago or I guess
longer now when Trump was elected
um I was surprised to see that they were
the ones going after her for this she's
out of step with a lot of Democrats on
this I mean we had the 2018 midterms was
called the camo wave where all of these
Democrats who had served Dana's favorite
Abigail spanberger Lisa slotkin Jason
Crowe all came into office with Seth
Moulton
um
who was elected in that
um we're a patriotic bunch I think what
she should have said was to explain why
she might not want that and to talk
about the term the poverty draft which
started in the 1980s that military
recruitment uh folks show up mostly at
low-income schools they go after Poor
Kids minority kids and I think that's
true it is well statistically it it is
true because I don't think the military
is not out there like there was no
people no there was a study out of
Connecticut from a few years ago looking
at how often uh there was Junior ROTC
recruitment going on at lower income
schools versus the wealthier schools and
they showed up but that makes sense
because you can't afford to go to
college so they're saying to you there's
a chance for you to go to college the
result doesn't necessarily mean intent
we'll be right back
that would have been a better way to
explain this versus coming off as if you
just hate the armed services judge what
do you think well I think there are a
lot of high-end people who believe that
the military and and high-value people
high value dollar people if you want to
call them that who see West Point and
some of these military academies as a
way to get into the upper echelon of
government in this country but you know
aside from that I I just don't
understand why she was jumping up and
down when she was talking about you know
why would they think that I would do
this up and down you know she called for
an end to Federal funding for military
recruitment in 2020. I mean you know
this is a woman who doesn't believe in
police she doesn't believe in the
military she doesn't believe in the
rules she doesn't believe in fossil
fuels this is a woman who what she wants
to do is she wants to fundamentally
change America she is part of this green
energy leftist Anarchy socialist group
nothing that she says impresses me and
nothing that she says bothers me because
anybody who goes up and down in a
message to everyone I don't know they
may have a problem I don't know you know
I gotta say she's really good with
filters I think she I think she's really
good at this stuff she is she's better
at that than being in Congress exactly
she spends more time doing that Kaylee
said last night on the show that she's
real sensitive about her left-wing flank
with the anti-war crowd remember she got
heckled a few times by these Ukraine
people that said why are you funding
this proxy war so she's very sensitive
she's like oh no no I don't have
anything to do with the military because
they actually got to the left of her on
something she doesn't want anybody to
work in her District she doesn't want
Amazon jobs she doesn't want you to join
the police force she doesn't want you to
join the military what other jobs are
left what's the recruitment events yeah
I mean what what exactly I guess maybe
you could volunteer to work for AOC
social media campaign exactly does she
understand the only reason she's able to
sit back and relax and spend a trillion
dollars on windmills is because because
we have such a great power for military
where we don't have to spend you know
we're not all there fighting all these
wars and defending our borders like that
we can we can spend on solar panels and
all of her green dreams it's a luxury it
is a luxury I say something that I
thought was very cool that there are
hundreds of thousands of people who've
earned American citizenship by serving
and that's a great thing to connect to
what's going on with people who want to
come to this country mandate it yeah
like for immigrants
[Laughter]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else